earlier today as i was taking a walk i
saw what for me at least
is the first monarch butterfly of the
season here
in the downtown of milwaukee i had gone
to the
central library which by itself is you
know a beautiful place
about which many stories could be told
and
i was picking up some books and then i
was walking back
by the garden by the milwaukee public
museum to see what flowers were in bloom
and there was a single monarch floating
around
from flower to flower and monarch
butterflies i think many of us
love them you know for their their
beauty and their
uh you know cool story about their
migration and all this other stuff that
you
you know either you know about or you
don't know about but if you don't know
about it you should go check on it
um my family has a particular
set of connections with monarch
butterflies
so in a way they're they're more
meaningful for me
in ways that they are for many other
people who have similar
traditions within their their own
families i think
and it has to do with my grandmother my
father's mother
and with my own mother so um
we're talking about ann sadler
originally ann dietz
and monique sadler originally monique
lemries
so my grandmother my dad's mother
was the second wife of my grandfather
joseph originally skufka and then
changed his name to sadler
and they they were really you know
deeply in love with each other
they only managed to have one child my
my dad
anton sadler who who lived they they had
some other
children who were born you know born
dead we call it stillborn
and one who died a month after birth so
my dad was an only child
from that marriage he actually had an
older half brother from a previous
marriage of my grandfather's
and my my grandmother sadler she was the
kind of person
who could just light up a room she was
very charitable
loving you know really smart
had a great eye for decor
and artwork and i just remember her
being a great person and when i've
talked with my relatives
about her they all you know talk about
how great she was and you know the
sort of things that she would do for
people they lived in a suburb
of chicago called arlington heights in
part because you know my grandfather was
making a lot of money
at that time and so that was kind of a
hoity-toity place
and unfortunately she ended up dying
in 1977 when i was only
seven years old of cancer and you know
if she were around today they probably
would have been able to
deal with it and give her treatment but
back then you know
in the in the 1970s many forms of cancer
were just going to kill you
i remember her being in an oxygen tent
at home and you know holding her hands
and and talking with us
even then and you know i was only seven
years old when she died and my sister
would have been
you know five i think yeah five years
old um
as well and so this is you know kind of
a big blow it was a big blow for my dad
and for my my grandfather a great loss
to the family
and then my dad died as many of you know
in 1982 when i was
11 years old almost you know just a
little bit before my 12th birthday
and my sister i think was uh nine at the
time
he was very young he was 36 years old my
grandmother was
herself pretty young she was in her 50s
when when she died
so a lot of a lot of tragedy on that
side of the family
and my grandmother really loved
monarch butterflies and she she actually
incorporated them
into a lot of the decor in her her house
in the 1970s and the 70s for those who
don't know about
aesthetics and you know culture and
stuff like that
it was a pretty wild time in terms of
the materials that were available and
the color schemes of things it was very
bright and colorful
in many ways and so she incorporated
you know these colors these oranges and
blacks and whites and yellows of the
monarch butterfly
into like you know glass sculptures and
decor and stuff like that and then
another thing that was really
quite important she didn't tell us kids
this at the time but she told this to
the older relatives
she was a very devout catholic as a
matter of fact she even taught ccd
as i i got to see when i went with her
to classes
and um you know like a lot of people
who are you could say
you know catholics and especially like
uh
catholics who have particular devotions
to
saints or live within certain
communities they often have a lot of
interesting ideas about you know what
god would allow you to do
or what you know what sort of
intercessions you might might work for
and
and so she said this she said
if i make it to heaven and i'm allowed
to do this
whenever the family is in trouble
i will send you monarch butterflies to
let you know that
everything is going to be okay and to
fortify you
in doing the sorts of things that that
you ought to do
to you know help you feel better to give
you a sign that
you're not alone all these sorts of
things
and nobody really took much notice of
that
at the time now monarch butterflies
as i'll talk about in a bit they're
really not uncommon at certain times of
the years in the midwest because we're
on a major
migration um you know
whatever you call it the path where they
they go and they
live on a lot of the native and
cultivated
um plants in in the areas we'll talk
about in a minute
but this story this this promise
it came to fruition when my dad died
so my dad dies in in august
august 2nd of 1982
at only 36 years old you know lingering
illness that takes him all the way up to
the mayo clinic
even they couldn't figure out what was
going on and he eventually
he eventually dies so
during the funeral which was
you know near well it would have been
genesee depot where saint paul's church
was and the saint paul
churchyard near the border of wales and
delafield
where where we lived where we had our
house where i grew up
um i remember all of us being there
at the the cemetery which i still go and
visit occasionally because both my
my dad and my mom and my grandpa and
grandma's ashes are buried there
and you know it was a typical sort of
thing you've got the the casket that's
being lowered into the ground
and all these people dressed in
uncomfortably hot clothing right because
it was suits and ties at the time
and fancy dresses and things like that
for funerals
even in the middle of an august summer
heat wave
and now i didn't see this but my mom
told this story later on she said as
the casket was being lowered into the
ground
you know and it's being lowered quite
slowly she saw a single monarch
butterfly
you know flit its way over land on the
casket
and she like she was you know thinking
well
maybe i'm i'm stricken with grief and
i'm hallucinating or something like that
so she bumps her friend uh standing next
to her and she's like do you see that
and her friend's like see what
you see that monarch butterfly on the
casket her friend says
yes so what there's a butterfly and
the butterfly went all the way down into
the grave
with the casket as it was being lowered
and my mother interpreted that
as a sign that my grandmother
ann sadler was sending you know
a sign to to not be worried and it was a
time when we were
very worried i mean my dad was the bread
earner
and um you know we were supposed to go
down to houston
uh where we were you know before he got
sick we were getting set to move
he'd recently uh had us purchase this
you know this boat
which we had to sell to one of our
neighbors on the cheap
and you know my family was going from
the
middle class that they'd clawed their
way into over the years back down into
the working class my mom had to go to
work within months of my
my dad dying and and there were
questions about you know
what all this was going to mean for us
so this is you know a significant time
and you know think about my mom
36 years old and
her she becomes a widow with with two
young children um so that certainly
would be a time
worth worrying about and so
you know however you want to interpret
this my mom took that
as a sign from grandma sadler that
things were going to be okay
and my mom took the monarch
as sort of her symbol just like her
mother-in-law
anne sadler had and she you know she had
brooches and she had jewelry of other
sorts and
things made for her to kind of
commemorate that
and you know it's um
it's something that has sort of
proliferated
into my generation i don't know how my
sister feels about it exactly but i know
for myself that there have been many
times
where things were going really look like
they were going south for me
in many respects i've had kind of a
tumultuous life
you know often lurching from one crisis
to the next
and quite often i will
wind up even out of season seeing a
monarch
doing something what should i make of
this is it grandma sadler is it my mom
you know asking for permission to
somehow
you know do weird things in the
background
who knows you know i mean i'm not a
superstitious kind of person
um but maybe there's maybe there's
something to this you never you never
really know and i
i it's a wonderful set of memories that
i have it
every time that i do see a monarch
in these sort of circumstances i'm
reminded of my mom and i'm reminded of
my
grandma you know ann sadler and monique
sadler two
really wonderful people to to people
that
made other people's lives so much better
in
so many respects and um
you know really made a huge impact on on
me
and i want to talk just a little bit
about monarchs before i end this
so the monarch butterfly again if you
haven't seen
one you know google it they're beautiful
they're these
dark orange butterflies with you know
black
ribs in their wings and they live
on things like um you know in the carrot
family
queens and lace and if you have a
carrots in your garden
monarch caterpillars which are this
beautiful
you know black and white and yellow
striped things will come on them and
land
and and eat them up there's other things
that they like as well
milkweed which makes them poisonous
that's why
birds don't don't mess with them there's
even a butterfly that isn't the monarch
but
pretends to be the monarch so that birds
will leave it alone as well
and you know right now
it's unusual even to see one later on in
the summer
we'll see lots and lots of them and by
you know by by the fall they're already
starting to migrate southward
and you know this is kind of a cool
story there's there's an area in mexico
where the monarchs the all the ones that
are still alive because many of them die
you know on the way they will fly all
the way from here or even as
far north as parts of canada down to
mexico
and congregate in this very small
area in which there'll be you know i
don't know
millions of these beautiful butterflies
and then you know as winter ends they
will make their way
back north lay their eggs the
caterpillars will hatch
they'll eat they'll turn into these uh
again you know very
stunning green chrysalises and then
then the monarch butterflies themselves
will come out and so
i've you know even before my grandma
sadler died
i i was always when i'd see monarch
butterflies i thought they're the most
beautiful of the
butterflies that we had here in in
wisconsin
because it was mostly monarchs and then
a few other things and moths and then
our sulphur butterflies which are also
pretty but they're not monarch pretty so
um
you know that's a little bit about my
family's
connection attachment
you know weird beliefs about the monarch
butterflies they're they're also
important in other people's heritage
as well but um you know
i think in different ways so
perhaps you find it interesting perhaps
you find it uh
kind of silly or something like that but
i have this this very strong attachment
it gives me much
joy to see them so i was very happy
today to see
the first monarch of the season
you